good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the noble tonight we'll hear
from guest author Darren's tell off
discussing his new book Hamilton Adams
Jefferson the politics of enlightenment
and the American Founding Deron is a
history teacher at City College and the
Graduate Center of the City University
of New York he also wrote the making of
an American thinking class intellectuals
in intelligentsia in Puritan
Massachusetts ladies and gentlemen
please welcome Darren Stella
thank you very much for that welcome and
thank you very much for for coming to
this event what I'd like to do is just
begin by saying a few words about what
I've tried to do with this book how I've
organized it and what I'm trying to
achieve and then tell you a little bit
about what I think some of the important
themes in it are and then we two two
very brief passages but first let me
begin by saying the kind of approach I'm
trying to take in this book a lot of ink
has been spilled on founding fathers and
on founding studies and much of it is
excellent work what I've tried to add
that's different is to combine what is I
think by now a fairly well-known
political narrative with the
intellectual and social history which is
not always as present in popular history
but tried to do it in such a way that
it's still engaging and still fresh and
not something that only an expert can
can have interest in probably the most
obvious question in explaining this book
is to begin with the title Hamilton
Adams Jefferson why these three people
in some sense it's an almost obvious
choice between these three you have
figures who are at the center of every
political event in the early republic
probably for about 1765 up to the 1820s
I mean these are three figures who
dominate the a
but I would argue that there's even a
more important reason they dominate that
age
more so than probably anyone else except
for George Washington because each is
the representative leader of one of the
three distinctive regions that made up
America and that's something that I
think a lot of contemporaries now don't
necessarily appreciate that even at the
moment of the Revolution in the early
republic America was an extremely
diverse place diverse ethnically
religiously but also socially and
geographically and in a lot of ways what
made these figures so critical and
important was that they were the
recognized leaders of their regions I
mean John Adams was the quintessential
Yankee Alexander Hamilton was the
ultimate Gotha might you know the
fast-talking
well-dressed elegant man about Manhattan
and Thomas Jefferson was the Virginian
par excellence the Virginia Squire that
you know of legend and so I thought
using these three figures would allow us
to see in part the differences that made
up America but also the other part of
the the title the politics of
enlightenment the way these three
figures appropriated a shared and common
cultural tradition and that's the part
of the history of ideas or intellectual
history that I really want I think is
critical and I want to bring to the fore
which is that the American nation was
founded at a particularly propitious
moment for political founding for
Constitution writing for early political
development and that was the
Enlightenment and because we've all
grown up with the Enlightenment it's so
obvious to us that we fail to appreciate
what an incredible impact it had and I
what I've tried to do at the very
beginning of the book in a very brief
introduction for those who haven't
looked at the Enlightenment for a while
is to just give you a general sense what
were the major issues if you have looked
at the Enlightenment recently feel free
to skip it but what I argue is that the
Enlightenment really is the beginning of
the cultural and intellectual
of modernity it's the beginning of
essentially our world in our worldview I
mean by that that in the Arab era before
the Enlightenment the goal of government
if you were a classical Republican was
the production of virtuous citizens if
you were a devout Christian
it was piety but if you were enlightened
you want to neither virtue or piety per
se you wanted the pursuit of happiness
and pleasure and it defined a culture
that was not meant to cohere around one
shared salvific goal or a shared
political credo but rather a culture
that was meant to be pluralistic and a
politics that were meant to be secular
this was also the first cultural moment
when people looked at the relationship
between the present in the past and said
the present may not be worse than the
past
classical Republicans Protestants and
Catholics alike all agreed that the age
in which they lived was an age of
declension the great republics existed
in Rome in Greece the strong time of
religion was the Apostolic fathers in
the early church the enlightened were
the first to say that the modern age is
not only different but better that
technology Commerce and science had
produced this wholly new concept called
progress and I think it's important that
these three figures brought that
cultural tradition to bear on the
founding of this country I would urge
that they did so in different ways
precisely because they came from
different backgrounds socially as well
as regionally they appropriated
different things from the Enlightenment
what Hamilton took from the
Enlightenment was essentially the
Scottish celebration of Commerce and
that was natural he lived on 57 Wall
Street he lived right next to the
exchange and when he thought about the
glories of modernity he thought about a
modern commercial age that created
social mobility
economic dynamism and powerful
government and for that reason what he
what he drew out of the Enlightenment
and brought to bear on our early
government was the goal of a strong
federal republic one that would have
powerful resources both in peace and in
war a realistic foreign policy based on
a very frank assessment of what was
possible and what was desirable a
realization that political rhetoric must
be bound by the dictum ought implies can
that you cannot embrace as a political
ideal something you don't have the
resources to accomplish you must be
realistic but more than anything
hamilton sought to build to create a
strong federal government to promote one
of the central projects of the
Enlightenment which was economic
development and particularly an economic
development that would produce
urbanization Commerce and manufacturers
in short Hamilton wanted to use the
federal government to make America look
like Manhattan to make it all look a lot
like New York Adams by contrast being
the great New England Yankee took a
different element from the Enlightenment
he certainly was aware of the elements
that Hamilton drew on they were in the
same party he backed almost all of hat
Hamilton's agenda but Adams also
inherited the great Puritan legacy that
made up Yankees curtains were people who
were very animated by a concern to
interrogate their conscience and be
painstakingly honest they kept journals
to mark their spiritual progress while
Adams was not a Calvinist he was not a
Puritan
but he was a kind of secularized Puritan
and he kept a journal too to mark his
own intellectual cultural progress and
what he took from the Enlightenment or
brought to the American enlightenment
and to our political tradition I would
argue is the New England strain of
skepticism of searing self honesty and
conscience and that meant that in an age
where Hamilton celebrated capitalism is
the solution to all social problems
Adams said capitalism is probably
best system we have but it's no panacea
and it will create its own unfairness
and injustice --is where others
celebrated if the rise of the common man
to power Adams who was a common man
himself said the common man will be no
more virtuous than the elites and
neither to be trusted that government of
a Republican nature and freedom will
persist only so long as no social group
whether it's the elite or the or the
people ever controlled political
dominance more than anything he thought
the way to achieve that was through
ornate checks and balances and he was
the first to come up with the ornate
scheme we know of in our Federal
Constitution he did it in 1780 and that
was really the the central part of what
he took out of the Enlightenment the
fact that a prudent statesman always
expects political leaders ultimately to
be knaves whether they really are or not
and that you should plan for them to be
a bit dishonest Jefferson and when some
ways had the most transcendent role
began in many ways as the most
enlightened of these three figures he
was deeply immersed in it and that was a
real challenge for a Virginian because
the Enlightenment in France in the
Netherlands in England and Scotland and
in America celebrated the modern
commercial age and an age of free labor
which is exactly what you don't find in
Virginia it's a slave dominated Society
and Jefferson tried to enlighten
Virginia to bring to bear on it the the
learning that would help people
understand the need to abolish slavery
to promote manufacturers to create
commercial development to create a more
dynamic and educated society all three
of these figures entered the revolution
with high hopes and aspirations all
three of them found them dashed by
historical experience and that's one of
the other themes I want to stress that
American politics of enlightenment
reacted to the realistic phenomena of
fighting a Revolutionary War and of
creating a political order and what
Jefferson did really was create a new
of politics beginning in the 1780s I
think he breaks with the politics of
enlightenment becomes America's first
great romantic visionary he does this in
notes on the state of Virginia he does
it in his correspondence and he does it
in his political rhetoric in the 1790s
where men like Hamilton and Adams had
come up with a politics of programs we
all want to promote wealth let's use
social science to figure out what sorts
of political programs will promote the
greatest social wealth Jefferson came up
with a politics of principle where
political community would be created by
deeply shared ideological beliefs where
the Enlightenment had embraced urbanity
and and Commerce and manufacturers
Jefferson discovered the agrarian idle
that what enlightened authors had called
rustic simplicity and the way they
considered the country the land of bores
bumpkins and booby Squires Jefferson
invoked an agrarian idle which said
quite the opposite what life in the soil
is an honest life it's a life of virtue
and in a lot of ways he became the prose
poet of American politics I would stress
again that all three of these responded
to not only regional influences their
social backgrounds but also the
political history that they experienced
as revolutionaries and in fact I've
structured each of the chapters dealing
with them around first a brief character
portrait then a discussion of what were
their views at the time of the
revolution and then each one has a
section called the turning how their
worldview changed as a result of their
experience of the American Revolution in
the war for independence then a
statement of their mature vision
Hamilton is the Enlightenment fulfilled
Adams the Enlightenment transcended he
becomes a great gadfly and Jefferson the
politics of American romanticism and
then I end with a very brief statement
of suggesting what their legacies are
both in their time and in ours and what
I'd like to do now is just read two
brief legacy statement
one on Adams and the other on Jefferson
and then open the floor for questions
and comments and discussion so let me
begin with Adams the legacy section is
called monuments will never be erected
to me the legacy of John Adams John
Adams live 26 years in retirement the
first half were spent fretting about his
legacy throughout his career he had
courted unpopularity by taking
principled stands in opposition to
public opinion whether defending the
British soldiers charged in the Boston
Massacre denying the natural equality of
men decrying the excesses of the French
Revolution or making peace in opposition
to the war hawks in his own party Adams
took a peculiar pride in his posture as
an independent gadfly he fully expected
to alienate many of his countrymen by
these acts and it was in part that
expectation doesn't that made his action
seem so heroic to himself faced with the
calumny of his contemporaries he saved
his aching vanity with the hope that
posterity would recognize his greatness
in his retirement however he began to
lose faith in this hope his career would
not vindicate him because history itself
was hopelessly corrupt I doubt whether
faithful history ever was or ever can be
written he complained to his old friend
Benjamin Rush his legacy was in doubt
for a man of Adams soaring vanity and
accomplishment such a fate was
unendurable what Adams could not stomach
it was a growing suspicion that he was
being robbed in the public mind of
credit for his accomplishments by other
less worthy figures for two years he had
labored in the Continental Congress for
independence the one man most
responsible for its eventual adoption
yet his historical role had been
upstaged by quote the theatrical show of
the Declaration of Independence
Jefferson ran away with all the stage
effect of that and all the glory of it
he
the better part of a decade in vital
Diplomatic Service none of which could
compete with the popular image of
Franklin as America's great diplomatic
genius his thoughts on government were
eclipsed by pains common sense
justices defense of the Constitution's
and discourses on Davila were dwarfed by
the Federalist Washington's
administration was already immortalized
by what Adams called the impious
idolatry to Washington and Jefferson's
will be quoted by philosophers as a
model of profound wisdom his own by
contrast will have no character at all
mausoleums statues monuments will never
be erected to me he complained managed
erekle romances will never be written
nor flattering oration spoken to
transmit me to posterity in brilliant
colors as ever
Adams vision proved depression he has no
monument or holiday to commemorate him
his face does not even appear on our
currency in the first dozen years of his
retirement Adams vainly struggled
against his fate in 1802 he began
working on his autobiography he got as
far as the beginning of his diplomatic
tenure when he abandoned the project in
1809 he commenced the publication of a
series of essays and documents in the
Boston patriot in defense of his
handling of the quasi-war one of the
wisest most virtuous most successful and
most important actions of my life
humility was never a problem for John
Adams within a few years however his
interest flagged and he stopped writing
Adams never could tell his own story
lacking the ability to control his
emotions he often fell into tangential
asides of strident self-justification
and equally strident accusations of his
adversaries more than that he was simply
too honest to sing his own praises in a
sustained fashion I look so much like a
small boy in my own eyes he wrote to
rush that with all my vanity
I can't endure the sight of it
Adams's did at last find his path to
fame on January 1 1812 he resumed his
correspondence with Thomas Jefferson the
bitter election of 1800 had doused the
already flickering embers of their old
friendship jefferson considered adams an
apostate to the revolutionary creed
adams saw The Virginian as a political
intriguer
for years Benjamin Rush a Philadelphia
physician and mutual friend from the
days before independence have been
trying to reconcile the two old comrades
he considered the North and South Poles
of the American Revolution
renewed correspondence with Jefferson
would not only do great honor to Adams
Russia shorten it would afford him the
opportunity to examine the scenes of
business in which they had been engaged
and all the errors of opinion and
conduct conduct into which they had
fallen in short it was a perfect venue
for stating his case to future
generations at the very outset of 1812
Adam sent Jefferson as a friend to
American manufacturers a brief letter
with two pieces of homespun two volumes
of his sons led lectures on rhetoric and
oratory thus began the most remarkable
correspondence in American political
history perhaps the greatest work of
early American letters the Adams
Jefferson correspondence was clearly
written for posterity
both pretended otherwise Jefferson
feigned shocked that a printer has had
the effrontery to propose publication
Adams claimed indifference Jefferson's
letters he assured him do you no
dishonor while in his own case my
reputation has been so much the support
of the public for 50 years and will be
with posterity that I hold it a bubble a
gossamer that idles in the wanton summer
air nothing could have been further from
the truth each sought to direct the
correspondence into channels that would
best serve his reputation
thus Jefferson resisted Adams subtle
attempts in the first year to broach
their political differences
Jefferson preferred to present himself
in a posture of serene retirement above
the fray of partisan political squabbles
Adams would have none of it he fired
back a volley of letters stating his
political position and pointing Lee
demanded that you and I ought not to die
before we have explained ourselves to
each other
sensing his old friends desperate need
to speak his mind in the status case
Jefferson relented and allowed himself
to be led on this epistolary excursion
by the bumptious Yankee he was in for a
wild ride in addition to discussing
politics past and present and history
ancient and modern Adams controlled
Jefferson in two debates on ethics
religion theology metaphysics
epistemology Indian Affairs Hindu
cosmology and literary criticism no set
of documents can match this
correspondence in revealing the minds of
these two men after breaking the ice
Adams dominated their ensuing
correspondence part of this dominance
came from sheer effort Adams wrote over
two-thirds of the roughly 160 letters
they exchanged Adams was also the better
epistolary stylist Jefferson's stately
and lofty missives seemed almost
pedantic in contrast to what Rush called
Adams elevated a nervous style where
Jefferson was ponderous and earnest
Adams was playful humorous even
mischievous Rush had warned Jefferson
that some of his thoughts Electrify me
most of all however Ammon Adams
dominated the correspondence by force of
argument Jefferson may have had more
intellectual breadth than the older
Yankee but on those matters he cared
about Adams had a depth of knowledge and
insight that The Virginian could not
hope to match and since Jefferson
graciously allowed Adams to steer the
discourse Adams selected those topics he
was strongest at the correspondence with
Jefferson was a tonic for Adams frayed
self-esteem as his principal modern
biographer is noted he was no longer the
bitter vindictive man he had been when
he departed Washington Adams had
mellowed secure and the knowledge the
atlast secured some
legacy for posterity the correspondence
with Jefferson was his monument Alby at
a literary one it associated his name
with jad of that of Jefferson and served
to remind Americans of his contribution
to the two men's mighty collaboration in
securing independence in the Continental
Congress this association was only
strengthened by the fortuitous fact that
they both died on the same day July 4th
1826 the 50th anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence with
Jefferson and Washington he was now one
of the eternal heroes of 1776 although
primarily associated with American
independence and popular consciousness
Adams has had far more profound
if subtle legacies not the least of
these have been cultural Adams was the
first of a long line of Yankee gadfly's
men with a strong contrarian streak who
stood against the overwhelmingly
optimistic strain of American culture as
a youth Adams had been charged by his
friends Jonathan Sewell and Daniel
Lennard with a little capillary vein of
satire meandering about in my soul and
had broke out such strangely suddenly
and irregularly that it was impossible
ever to foresee when it would come and
how it would appear well that same vein
of satire can be found in the writings
of subsequent Yankee contrarians like
Herman Melville William Gaddis and
Thomas Pynchon their system novels mimic
Adams insufferably long-winded in
tangential style just as they share
Adams ironic vision that life and
history too close critic disclose
critical truths to which those living
and making history will ever be
oblivious this ironic and skeptical
strain in American thought first
exemplified by Adams has supplied the
national culture with what Frederick
Nietzsche called
the intellectual conscience curmudgeonly
gadflies like Adams have kept our
culture at least minimally honest the
truth is out there Adams tells us if
only we have the courage to pursue it
John Adams greatest legacy however was
political the great apostle of balance
Adams constitutional musings were
predicated on his conviction that no
political party movement or leader was
immune to the corruptions of human
nature he did not deny the existence of
virtuous and disinterested political
leaders
he simply insisted that they are not
enough in any age or any country to fill
all the necessary offices trust no one
was his Creed
especially those whose quote
hypocritical pretense of
disinterestedness and public virtue were
set up to deceive the people and take
advantage of their ignorance and
credulity to protect the people from
such intriguers Adams championed the
ornate system of checks and balances and
separation of powers that inform
American constitutional government in
the years since his death American
voters have seen these constitutional
checks and balances transformed by an
imperial presidency and an active
judiciary the direct election of
senators has reduced the difference
between the two branches of the
legislature to one of duration in office
instinctually the American people have
compensated by devising an electoral
strategy to achieve a damn ziyan balance
the American penchant for divided
government unique among Western
democracies has served as an
extra-constitutional means of checking
political power what critics decry as
gridlock is in fact American government
working exactly as Adams desired
American voters divided power within the
federal government
precisely because like Adams they know
that neither party is entirely right or
disinterested they divide power because
they know that neither party has a
monopoly on virtue or can be completely
trusted they divide power because they
know that the ensuing interminable
partisan strife checks the worst
excesses of the most powerful most
important they divide power because they
know as
insisted that as long as neither party
achieves true dominance republican
government persists and with it our most
precious liberties this is john adams
greatest legacy all in all not bad for a
curmudgeon okay now I'd like to read
briefly the legacy of Thomas Jefferson
take care of me when dead the legacy of
Thomas Jefferson America's founding
fathers had played a pivotal role in
history the progenitors of the first
successful revolution in modern history
they'd assured in a new political epoch
that would transform Pollock's politics
and society in every corner of the world
they also knew that their contributions
would ultimately be judged by posterity
and it was that judgment that animated
their careers and informed their writing
more than any other generation of
American statement statesmen the
founding fathers were obsessed with
their legacies Thomas Jefferson was no
exception in the last decade of his life
he was consumed with the need to set the
historical record straight perhaps even
more than his old friend John Adams
Jefferson consistently defended his
tenure as governor of Virginia and
rejected any attempts to question either
the centrality or the originality of his
Declaration of Independence in numerous
letters he denigrated his rivals such as
Patrick Henry and Alexander Hamilton and
stressed the critical importance of his
own contributions to the early republic
the year before the Missouri controversy
erupted he began composing his Annis a
survey of the political battles in the
1790s three years later he commenced
drafting an autobiography both works
presented their author as a high man
minded man of principle both depicted
his opponents as dangerous ante
Republican and self-serving ultimately
both were abortive like Adams in his
essays in the Boston Patriot Jefferson
was unable to sustain the
effort necessary to complete his
justification in his final year returned
to his closest friend and associate
James Madison with one last request
knowing the death was knocking at his
door he implored his fellow Virginian to
quote take care of me when dead he could
impose no greater burden in the years
after his death
Jefferson's imprimatur would be claimed
by a broad range of Americans northern
workers hailed him as the Democratic
champion of a common man southern slave
owning planters paid homage to his
defense of states rights both Jefferson
Davis and Abraham Lincoln invoked the
Madol mantle of the sage of Monticello
as have Newt Gingrich and Bill Clinton
in our own day indeed no other American
Statesman's words have been cited so
often and for such diametrically opposed
purposes one legacy however is
incontestable Thomas Jefferson created
the visionary politics of American
Romanticism his politics of principle
transcended the mundane realm of
programs and policies and introduced an
idealistic often otherworldly character
into American political discourse it is
this visionary character for more than
the particular principles Jefferson
ascribed to that is his greatest and
most enduring contribution to American
life his soaring rhetoric and romantic
sensibilities transformed the politics
of American of the American nation since
his day every major political movement
has needed some set of transcendent
principles to rally the populace whether
new nationalism or new freedom new deal
or new frontier Great Society or
mourning in America Republicans and
Democrats greens and militiamen all
wrapped their programs in a rhetoric of
glorious ideals and sacred principles
after Jefferson every successful
American politician
had to evoke the vision thing and all
successful political movements have
deployed a visionary rhetoric this
Jefferson's greatest legacy has been
decidedly mixed in its results
the visionary character of Jeffersonian
political discourse has often served to
obscure the real sufferings and in
justices in American society under
patinas of glittering principles and
abstract ideals in his own day the dogma
of limited government and states rights
served to include any meaningful
national discourse about the future of
slavery in the early republic just as
his agrarian idle through a web of
romantic rhetoric over the
underdeveloped and crude character of
southern rural society in the years
after his retirement manifest destiny
would give divine sanction to a brutal
an occasionally genocidal program of
conquest and expansion Woodrow Wilson's
rhetorical inflation of the First World
War into a struggle for global democracy
human rights and an end to all future
Wars was used to justify a draconian
suppression of dissent as was the
struggle to defend freedom from the
Menace of global communist
totalitarianism I'll be on a much
smaller scale in the 1950s even when it
has not been used to cover malevolent
actions Jefferson's romantic politics of
principle has had a disturbing effect
sincere devotion to abstract truths has
animated some of the most ferocious and
canine partisanship in our nation's
history and it's heightened ideological
differences among people whose practical
differences might have been easily
negotiated perhaps most insidious of all
subscribing to some transcendent vision
has for many Americans served as a proxy
for actually redressing the wrongs they
purportedly deplore maintaining an
authentic commitment to a virtuous
sentiment as all too often been a means
to claim a self-righteous moral
superiority that solves the moral
sensibilities of concerned citizens
without actually helping the objects of
their concern all too often
ever since politics of principles has
allowed Americans to sin with a good
conscience it was so in his own day as
well there is however a far more
positive sight to Jeff Jefferson's
visionary legacy in times of national
crisis his romantic rhetoric has proved
an irreplaceable resource for rallying
the American people precisely because of
its power to mobilize public opinion the
federal government has rarely had to
resort to outright repression and force
in moments of national emergency but
more than that the politics of principle
has throughout our history been a source
of inspiration and justification for
those who have sought to force the
nation to live up to its transcendent
ideals
the resource has been especially
valuable to those who have been denied
full access to the benefits of American
life or who have struggled against some
justices since Jefferson's day it has
been impossible to dismiss the dream of
any reformer
however utopian or radical as simply
unamerican the gap between romantic
rhetoric and tangible realities has been
a constant spur of renewal forcing all
those who deploy it to live up to its
ideals the visionary politics of
principle that Jefferson created as thus
exerted an incessant pressure on the
nation's public life one that demands
the actualization of lofty goals and the
enactment of abstract principles the
visionary character of American
political discourse has sustained the
hopes of the disadvantaged and
maintained the faith of the American
people in their government and their
future Thomas Jefferson taught America
as a political entity to dream if he had
done nothing else in his long and
remarkable life he would still have
given us ample reason to take care of
him when dead
any questions yeah a question over here
well one second
[Music]
wonderful what do you call them founders
leaders leaders okay it's kind of think
of a real good word in relation to
separation of search of education and
church and state
excellent question really two questions
that one was their view of education and
then what separation of church and state
all three of them favored public
education in fact Adams in his
constitution of 1784 Massachusetts which
is the only revolutionary constitution
that is still in operation they haven't
rewritten it I actually put in a a
clause saying that the state of
Massachusetts should support universal
public education for all citizens and as
well as support higher education the
college and university level and the
advancement of scientific and cultural
development in you know things like
historical societies and he himself it
helped found the major scholarly society
in new england jefferson tried to get a
system of public education in place for
virginia it was unsuccessful it was part
of his frustration at the politics of
enlightenment he tried to bring it but
but the political class the leadership
of virginia would not put up with it
hamilton too favored public education in
some ways you could see why he would the
most he was the poorest of the three he
was an illegitimate son who had gotten
to the United States from the kindness
of strangers basically and it was his
college education that made him what he
was now about the separation of church
and state certainly the in the
Enlightenment core culture is secular
right secular humanism is the
Enlightenment is an Enlightenment
project
however it's a complicated question
because while the enlightened in cells
were for the most part deus or had
religious convictions that were less
than fully religiously orthodox they had
great respect for the orthodoxy of the
masses so Adams himself didn't believe
in that Jesus was the son of God neither
did Thomas Jefferson and it's just an
interesting fact but Jefferson
nonetheless remained the vestry men in
his church and supported it and Adams
continued to stick by the Congregational
churches although he was in fact
theologically a Unitarian but he thought
you know the people respect these
congregational beliefs and it's
important that they be respected so
their basic view was you know insofar as
the question becomes how do we make
sense of the first another there were
still politicians but also that was part
of the code of the Enlightenment the
Enlightenment was a very urbane and it
was a movement among the minority of
Americans and Europeans and they never
what they wanted was toleration for
their own perspective they didn't want
to impose their perspective on the rest
of society so they said as long as you
let us be you know heterodox were more
than happy to let you be Orthodox but
neither of us should be able to dictate
our desires to the political culture so
there's kind of a neutrality I guess
you'd say question over here
you think was at the center of the
long-running dispute between Adams and
Jefferson other than Adams own tortured
personality and his insecurities what
else do you think help play that dispute
between the two of them do you think
that their upbringing and Adams strong
religious background playing a factor I
mean you thought he was more moral than
Jefferson no Adam certainly thought so
well let me first say that the issues
you raised which is his tortured
personality and his anxieties and
insecurities did have a lot to do with
it
part of it was philosophical they really
looked at the world differently yeah
Adams as I say was not particularly
worth a Doc's but he was a secular
Calvinist he didn't believe in Calvinism
but he did think people were basically
dangerous and sinful and had to be
watched carefully and he didn't think he
was an excel fan exception Jefferson was
filled with optimism about human nature
and Adams who was eight years older than
Jefferson and cared about him for a long
time like a younger brother thought you
know poor innocent Tom he'll just he's
never gonna grow up he's never gonna
realize he's gonna be taking an
advantage of time and again and then
when they became political rivals he
discovered something which is that
Jefferson was brilliant and an amazing
political leader he also had the
remarkable ability to change his beliefs
with absolute sincerity when it was
convenient so that he could pass the
lighted test to Detective test and I
think he deeply cared about Adams but he
hired muckrakers to say horrible things
about him and he was able to say well I
didn't know they were gonna say horrible
things although obviously did that's all
these guys did they were hacks oh
absolutely the the Gaiden a that at the
time the Karl Rove of the time or
Carville whoever you want was a guy by
the name of James Tom James Callender
and he wrote a book paid for by
Jefferson about Adams which he called
them hoary headed incendiary and when
Adams found out that Jefferson wrote it
he just could never forgive him now the
irony is Jefferson in his own part
didn't think he did anything long
because he didn't write the book
and well Kalin went too far but Adams
you really were a little bit off
off-base and he figured that calendar if
he's extreme it's because of the purity
of his principles well he found that
later that Adams was kind of right about
this this sort of rhetoric because after
Jefferson beats him in the election
calendar says well I hope you're gonna
give make me the postmaster of Richmond
and Jefferson no I'll give you ten
dollars go away and so he moves to
Richmond then says well I can do another
expose I hear there's a story that
there's some slaves who live in your
house that look just like you and that's
how I know about Sally Hemings he's the
one who broke that story so and you
through did a great letter Abigail Adams
writes to him and says you know I'm
really sorry that this came out but it
couldn't happen to a nicer guy question
over here you all realize that Adams had
a forget race of personality collision
but he was one of our great founding
fathers and you made a point earlier
that when you think of all the great
tributes monuments especially State
Hamilton last year the anniversary of
the duel and but you see nothing for
Adams you seen very little mm-hmm
and even commercia commercially in
commercially in the late in the last few
decades
Jefferson Hamilton there are so much in
the way of monuments and tributes and
again almost crass commercialization and
again very little towards Adams
unfortunately well I think Adams is
beginning to get his innings
you know David McCullough's biography
certainly brought him to public
attention as the Joe Ellis is fine
biography of him as well to be fair
Adams is a very strange character I mean
he's curmudgeonly he's known to be
incredibly vain and difficult and
irritable yet he's extremely self-aware
he knows he's vain he knows he's
curmudgeonly and it's a real acquired
taste and one and I what happened to the
scholars is once they acquire the taste
they all fall in love
atoms and that's that's what Russia told
Jefferson if you store corresponding
with him you will love him and Jefferson
says the same thing to madam Madison if
you know him he's crazy he's you know
difficult but you'll love him he's the
most honest man imaginable he doesn't
have the kind of personality that's
likely he doesn't have a face you'd put
on a Mount Rushmore right he's got
mutton-chop whiskers he's fat he's got
no chin he's bald
he you know had a horrible temper
Jefferson was his vice president we mom
told tales of cabinet meetings where his
cabinet officers would disagree with him
and Adams would pull off his wig and
throw it on the ground start stamping
and that's that's definitely Adams but
as they say it's an acquired taste and I
I don't think he expected that a
majority of people would be taken with
him but if there's a small number of
people who appreciate his contribution
in some ways that's enough because I
think people privately know that his
idea of trust no one divided government
you know don't trust him as far as you
can kick him it's kind of true and so
there's a certain sense in which
Americans are all Jeffersonians were
optimistic filled with soaring hopes but
there's a part of us and the reason why
this country keeps going is mostly
Jeffersonians were the partner in the
back of our heads this is yeah but be
careful be prudent and and I think
that's that's a very real part of our
American political culture and I think
it's a damn Jim I think he's one of the
reasons why the Civil War started when
you go back from the Kentucky resolution
his opinions in the Missouri Compromise
I mean he was just so duplicitous that
just the way the Constitution was
written and what I really wanted to say
also is that when you're talking about
checks and balances I really think
that's revisionist history if you read
there's nothing in the Constitution says
checks and balances and if you read all
the different writings of the founding
fathers
nothing does I think it's just people
want to say it this it's because it just
seems nice they really want us long
strong legislative body they weren't
they wanted a weak presidency in
judiciary was this that's just the way
it was okay well let me let me deal with
those two excellent points in sequence
first about Jefferson's dishonesty
you know Joe Ellis has a great line he
said you know Jefferson anyone else
would be dishonest if they did what
Jefferson did but Jefferson is the
unique ability to believe what he's
doing at every moment and that's kind of
true he's a lucky guy he's you know a
true believer who believes in his own
virtue and once in a while we come
across politicians like that and they're
they're remarkable they can say one
thing today in the next thing tomorrow
and pass a lie-detector test
so I also I don't think you can quite
blame the Civil War on him he did not
act alone and there was a political
culture and a society yeah but I
understand you yes he said he had a very
southern policy and what was behind the
politics of principle of Jeffersonian
republicanism was ultimately a very
pro-southern position there's no
question of that the other question
about checks and balances and the goal
for a strong legislature and a weak
executive it's very interesting in 1776
there's no question that that's true you
find that in almost every state
legislature and in every new
constitution in some they don't even
have any meaningful executive at all and
they have a unicameral assembly like
Pennsylvania and Vermont there's one
exception to that and that's John Adams
he writes thoughts on government and he
uses the phrase checks and balances and
he puts it in a 17-8 Constitution from
Massachusetts where he gives he's the
first to do this he says we need an
independently elected executive with a
legislative veto and a Senate that is
elected on a different basis than the
house and an independent judiciary that
serves for life and can only be removed
by being impeached for high crimes and
misdemeanors and at the time that's just
considered very kind of reactionary but
within about seven or eight years guys
like Madison and Jay and Hamilton meet
in Philadelphia and come up with the
exact same arguments and in his in his
justification for American
constitutionalism this really long
three-volume book called defense of the
American constitutions
Adams's uses that phrase checks and
balances over and over again in a letter
to to Jefferson Jefferson writes to him
and says you know America will remain
free as long as the people are virtuous
and as long as they're farmers they'll
be virtuous and Adams writes back and
says no checks and balances Jefferson
checks and balances
that's how long they'll stay free so
that's part of the reason he wasn't so
loved is because remember with the
principle of checks and balance why that
was controversial when you got strong
legislators it was because the
legislators were the voice of the people
right and the executive was something
else the voice did the elite so to say
checks and balances meant that we can't
trust the people that there has to be
something to check their will and that
Adamson system being a commoner himself
he said of course were no better than
anybody else so for that reason he's not
the most popular but I I do think checks
and balances is central to American
constitutionalism I have question back
here
what do you think each of your subjects
would say or believe about the current
probably minority movement in
jurisprudence of original intent of
interpreting the Constitution according
to the original intent of the founders
and I guess the other side of that just
to pontificate for two seconds would be
the Constitution as a living document
the number of Rights to be applied to
the new age as with the principles
inherent in it well it's an excellent
question and it's it's complicated
because they didn't use that phrase at
the time the first to actually talk
about original intent was Madison and
anytime you talk about original intent
the problem is whose intent the people
who wrote it well it was written by
committees that people who hated each
other and didn't agree it was all
compromises should it be the intent of
the the people who called for the
convention
well they had different views Madison
said it should be the views of the
people who ratified it well they had
different views so the original tense a
bit of a red herring the way it was
discussed at the time was should you
have a strict literal reading of the
Constitution or a broad and expansive
one and strict this closest thing they
had to the original intent argument and
that was Jefferson's position he said
read the Constitution as saying thou
thou shalt if it says thou thou shalt do
something you can do it but if it
doesn't you can't so if the Constitution
doesn't specifically say you can do
something then you can't do it Hamilton
took the opposite position he said if
the Constitution doesn't say he read as
that shalt mom if it doesn't say I can't
do something then I can do it and they
had intense arguments on a whole host of
issues most prominent on being the Bank
of the United States Hamilton wanted to
charter a bank to monetize the debt and
super-complicated explained in the book
but basically wanted to create the
Federal Reserve
system and he did and it worked
brilliantly it created money for the
nation and solved our debt problem and
Jefferson acknowledged it would be
useful but he said there's nothing in
the Constitution that says anything
about creating banks so in a strict
interpretation all powers in the 10th
court of the 10th amendment not given to
the federal government are reserved to
the states so you can't do it and
Hamilton's answer always was on
everything that he'd fight with
Jefferson about general welfare Clause
Constitution says I have the power to do
whatever is for the general welfare
certainly creating currency and ending a
depression isn't the general welfare
doesn't specifically say I can't make a
bank so common sense says we can find
the rights we need if we just apply
reasonable it was also a different way
of thinking about the Constitution
Jefferson thought of it as in a way the
way original intent jurists do now is a
bedrock document that lies out clearly
the frame of government Hamilton said
look it's a good first guess it gives us
some broad outlines but the details are
all going to be made up in the practice
and precedent and it'll change
what what would their view be on
judicial review which came about as a
result of marberry versus madison great
question
and and a bit complicated I don't know
what Adams view was or would have been I
suspect he would have been okay with it
he wanted a very strong judiciary
Jefferson never accepted judicial review
even after Marbury vs. Madison it's
settled nothing in his mind he called
those people consolidations and he
wanted to impeach the Supreme Court
justices did actually impeach some of
them he later on in his life when the
Marshall court continued to expand the
courts Providence said you know what we
should limit them to six year term of
office and make it renewable but
Congress and ultimately he said the real
judicial constitutional review is not
done by the Supreme Court it's done by
the states which is what he did with the
Kentucky resolutions each state judges
whether acts are constitutional and if
they don't like them just nullify them
repeal them that the court is has no
more authority over that than any other
branch Hamilton's the exact again
they're the perfect polarity exact
opposite Hamilton is probably the the
true author of judicial review he writes
it into the Federalist Papers now it's
not necessarily adopted in the early
courts before Marshall shows up but he
clearly has that in mind in fact there's
a famed quote that John Marshall told to
judge story on the Supreme Court
he said when it came to jurisprudence I
was a mere school child Alexander
Hamilton was my teacher Hamilton was the
most distinguished member of the New
York Bar when he studied it was real New
Yorker and he's a guy who you know
decides he wants to get a law degree
takes Jefferson seven years to do his
reading to get his law degree Adams
takes two years takes Hamilton six
months and he comes up with an he's just
a prodigious New Yorker I was with a
different way of doing it too instead of
studying coke he decides he's gonna
write up his own book of procedures of
the actual procedures that are used in
courts and when he's done it becomes the
standard study guide for the
bar exam in New York for a hundred years
I mean just changes the way people study
the law but he's very big on you
ditional review Hamilton is one of those
guys who believes in part because he
comes from the very bottom of society
and is an abolitionist that the courts
are the ones who are really going to
defend our liberties and ultimately
popular government isn't what we mean by
freedom it's important what's more
important is individual freedom and
liberty and that's going to come from
the courts yeah we've time for one more
question apparently
I just wondered how how did you choose
to leave Franklin out of this great
group that's a very very interesting
question I needed one guy to represent
the mid-atlantic and Franklin was a live
option except that Franklin dies before
the the founding period proper he dies
before the 1790s besides Franklin's
gotten a lot of ink and I must say I
teach up at City College and the grayned
which is Hamilton's estate is about a
block and a half from my office and I've
never seen anyone visited and he's
really the bastard of the founding
fathers and it's tragic because I think
in in terms of the politics of the early
republic of the constitutional federal
government he's much more important than
Franklin is I mean he's just